what happens can we save the shop most
of go are
last the others are too damaged to
sell what does that mean for us I went
to school
here run a business
here I took a wife and even raised a
child here and I still a foreigner to
these
people so it wasn't an accident was it
no it was the hry
brothers as behind on
rent so little man for little
man you went to a laone shark you've
already lost my mother to gambling now
our business what's next I've given you
too much Freedom if you think you going
to speak to me like this if this is
freedom you can have it just because you
talk about prepper you think you know
better than me I know better than to get
involved with criminals like little man
and his brothers I should have pulled
you out of school when your mother left
I should have put it be on account of
the shop see how goddamn lucky you are
lucky yes I worked at that shop since I
was a boy since my parents came to this
country changed their name and sacrifice
everything only for their son to raise
an ungrateful child who take after her
ungrateful H
mother you call her slur my mother half
of who I am didn't mean it
tellin you only see her half don't
you you don't even see yourself in
me how dare you judge me or my mother
you're an unfit parent and a drunk and
you can't stop me from being with Gibbs
or swimming in the Ste God Dam it and no
for your
mouth
how will we survive without the Shar
Pearl you'll find a way out to
this come
on let's
eat why couldn't mom have taken me with
her
he hates me because she left doesn't
he
no he hats
[Music]
himself